alright everyone welcome to ask Evan
episode number two or I am answering
your business questions to help your
company grow let's get right to it first
question comes from array who wrote in
the SE e ray who wrote in to say like
that what are some techniques on how to
get business ideas everything starts
with an idea how do you come up with the
idea so this is gonna be important okay
you want to have a successful idea you
want to have a successful business is
going to come from matching two things
and I have a sukkah guides oogle 101
that really helps you figure out what
your passion is and build the business
around it the the summary high level
without getting deep in the exercises is
you need to find something one that you
love to do you have to be passionate
about it right you have to you have to
make this your life's work if you look
at successful entrepreneurs and why they
started their business making money was
was great it became a byproduct of it
but they started their business because
they were really really passionate about
it they would do it even if they weren't
making money doing it so that's what you
need to find and if you haven't found
that yet then you need to explore you
need to try different things and it's
not just coming up with an idea stop
trying to be logical and think what
business ideas should I start go out and
do stuff try things go dancing take up a
snowboarding class whatever it is
explore get out of your comfort zone try
new things that that you're excited by
and go do them and see what happens
because out of that you'll discover what
you're passionate about if you know what
you're passionate about then the second
thing is you have to combine it with
something that helps people write
business is about providing value if you
provide value to people you'll make
money if you provide a lot of value to
people you make a lot of money so you
have to figure out the combination of
what you're passionate about with what
value you can bring the people how you
can help people out and if you have
something to your deeply passion boat
and that helps a lot of people that's a
recipe for a highly successful business
next up is another YouTube viewer love
you guys Sean afshar who wrote in to say
I'm thinking of starting on men's
clothing line I really like accessories
both ties POC
squares which one do you think would be
better to focus on Shawn another great
question and one that I get a lot from
entrepreneurs here's the thing I can't
tell you what businesses start I can't
tell you if its pocket squares if its
neck ties if it's something else because
it's really going to come down to which
one you're more passionate about because
if you go into a business just seeing
opportunity just trying to be successful
because you see a potential market there
it's not going to work it's whatever you
feel here because you can make any
business work if you're really
passionate and excited about it so where
is your passion line are you more
excited by bow ties and that's what you
really love but you figure I got to be
able to expand and set with these other
things or do you love the pocket squares
or do you love something totally
different it has to come from your heart
and if you're you're making your list of
things and potential ideas that go
through you have to listen to the one
that gets you excited because if you're
excited by then you'll put in the work
you'll run through the brick walls
you'll jump over any hurdle that comes
in front of you but if you're not
excited by it if it's just you know it's
an okay idea you think you make a lot of
money it's not going to work out so I
can't tell you what business to go into
nobody else can you have to listen to
your heart that's where it comes from
next up still van ova from youtube right
in the say thank you for your great
contribution to the world Thank You
Savannah love you for that question what
are your daily rituals thank you whoo
this is a really important one I don't
think entrepreneurs use their time well
just in general and and I don't blame
you you know as entrepreneurs we're
working crazy hours typically you're
doing everything yourself you don't have
resources you don't have the people you
don't have the money and so you're doing
everything yourself and you're not
you're not even totally sure what you
should be doing and so creating daily
rituals to keep you motivated and
inspired as well as focus on the right
task is super important so here's what I
do every morning during the weekday
starts basically the same I'll wake up
I'll get my phone and I'll send a quick
text to my wife because she's usually
already out the door and it's usually a
picture some cute animal something just
to let her know that I'm up
thinking about her have a quick chat
even when you start the day with a
little bit of love it helps to make them
feel great it makes you feel great next
I'll go get my vitamin water so we have
this uh get a glass of water and i'll
put some vitamin stuff in there I don't
really know what that does but my wife
is convinced it's awesome and healthy
for me so I do it so listen to your wife
next up now this is more important and
more serious ah music you got to put
music on put something on that gets you
excited that gets you bopping that gets
you moving that gets you energetic I
have a belief playlist whatever your
favorite songs are make a playlist that
you can put on in the morning that I
rotate through because you need energy
in the morning cuz mornings typically
suck right you may not have had a great
night's sleep and you know all that
energy that you had yesterday is gone
and you know you know may not feel the
momentum and you're starting off from
scratch again music gets you moving
music gives you excitement and energy
and you can pour that into whatever your
task is so whatever your favorite songs
are that get you doing this when it
comes on that's you should be listening
to every day and starting your morning
then big glass of water with lemon juice
you usually dehydrated in the morning so
you got to have that then I'll start off
reminding myself what my big why is so
my big wise help a billion entrepreneurs
and I believe that I can really make a
difference in the world as you so nicely
pointed out in your comment and so I
work towards on I try to use that as
something to inspire me and then I look
at my little wise and my little wise are
all the little wins that I've had
recently so typically for me I log on
and look at my youtube comments and you
two comments you guys post are always
great they make me feel awesome you know
you're spreading lots of love I'm trying
to help you 02 and you guys give me
energy every day but before I had
youtube comments I had a PowerPoint file
that just had quotes from people who had
seen me speak and said you know
fantastic presentation changed my life
all these great inspiring things and I
use that everyday as fuel to help me
remember that what I was doing was
really important because when you go to
a conference you're all excited you're
feeling a high that I may even last a
couple days and then your life kicks
back
again and and you start losing energy
and losing momentum and so having that
as a reminder helps you stay motivated
stay inspired stay excited state full of
energy to help you continue to go on top
of that I do different things on
different days so monday is my mid day
it'll be all the stuff I need to get
done for the week anything related to
you know special projects i'm working on
or posting for my facebook account or
whatever it is I'll line up everything
on Monday where I'm just sitting and
working don't talk to me don't email me
there's no phone calls there's no
interviews there's no video is happening
on monday it is just work tuesday is my
riding days i'm writing on a book and
it's a lot of work and there's a lot of
reviews there's a lot of edits publisher
back and forth and so I said I'll time
every week to focus on writing my book
and then also at the end my newsletter
so Tuesday's writing day Wednesday's
video day today is Wednesday what's up
I'm writing I make all my videos on
Wednesday answer your questions and I
just get in that zone right so I set up
ready to know that I'm gonna do videos
today I get excited I'm energetic it's
one of my favorite days of the week you
know I'll shave make sure I'm ready to
go get my t-shirt on whatever I'm
warning for the day and it helps you
because when you set different days for
different tasks you create a mindset
that fuels you for that day so what's
really hard for me is when I'm if I'm on
if it's Tuesday right and I'm and I'm
writing and I'm in writing mode and I'm
you know takes me 45 minutes to get back
into where i was before writing and
getting in the zone and now I'm deep
into it writing good you know and then I
can spend a couple hours there to stop
that pause and then go do a video well
will knock me off my game the video
won't be great the writing won't be
great and I'm too scattered over the
place so it's better to set yourself up
for success and chunk similar tasks at
similar times so when's it's all about
videos Thursday is my public-facing day
my public-facing day so that'll be radio
show that'll be
interviews that'll be meetings that'll
be phone calls anything where I'm
connecting with other people is usually
not a Thursday and so again you know I'm
ready to do I get shaved again i get my
t-shirt on or gear or whatever it's
gettin it's gettin snowy on if you could
see outside here it's no one here in
Toronto so I'm certainly where the
hoodies I guess for a go outside again
I'm getting set up to go and be ready to
meet people and be energetic and be
excited and be happy and it doesn't jive
while on my admin get stuff done day and
so it's easy to pace things out the
other thing that does for you is I set
my meetings back to back to back to back
so have a phone call another phone call
google hangout interview then meeting
somebody it's like all jam thursdays are
crazy pack it helps because normally if
you have time before meeting you're not
doing anything you're not being
productive 15 minutes before meeting or
before phone call you're getting ready
for the phone call you can't really
start on anything and if the person is
late then you know you're just waiting
and you're not getting anything done
that's like that's killing my time I
hate that and so I lined them back to
back to back to back I'm calling you if
we're doing a phone call so I'm never
late if you're doing meetings I'm doing
back to back to back at a starbucks so I
don't have to keep traveling and coming
back you're coming to see me and and it
works so daily morning rituals to
inspire you get you motivated get you
excited and then chunk in your task so
you have days for different things so
that it keeps you highly productive and
engage that was a long answer but I
Felton's important okay next up Pleasure
promises rights in another YouTube fan
rights in to say you are my inspiration
Evan please help me I'll do my best I
want to be a middle school leader the
applications have to be returned in a
couple days I'm passionate it's
something I want badly it's my dream my
dream but Evan I was new to this country
and my public speaking skills aren't
good enough I struggle with proper
English accent and fluency and you don't
know how badly I want to get it out of
my way on one hundred percent sure my
application will be accepted but then
comes a speech in front of 300 students
I'm afraid of I have to speak the
determination to be a captain is killing
me every day and I don't know how I will
do it
what do i do Evan please tell me a few
days to go and bam I mean I mean in
front of the stage of the crowd this is
letting me down from achieving my dream
I'm an extreme hard worker and always
excel because of it yet Evan I'm scared
of that day i'm scared i know i won't be
able to do it properly please I beg you
please help me ASAP I'm dying to see
your help this is a great question and
one congrats and having the courage and
inspiration to reach for your dreams
even though you're scared this is this
is going to happen you know what any
dream you have you want it to happen
it's going to be scary you're going to
have to jump outside your comfort zone
you're going to do things that you've
never done before you operate in the
bubble we all do we operate this bubble
and if you want your dreams to happen
you got to be able to go out here you
got to expand that circle and that's
gonna be scary and you're gonna have to
push you're going to be the little man
telling you all the reasons why it's not
going to happen need to stop being your
own worst little man that's what you
need to do because people don't really
care about your accent you know I saw
passion come through in this question
and that's all that matters you have to
get up there and talk about why it's is
important to you you know most people
middle school they're not that excited
about their school right and having you
come up and speak passionately about it
is the equalizer I don't care if you
can't speak perfect English or not and
we all have these limiting personal
beliefs so for you the story you're
telling yourself is I can't be
successful because i'm not fluent in
english we're all going to have these
stores right you're going to some people
say i won't be successful because I'm
too old I won't be successful because
I'm too young I won't be such as because
I'm a man I won't be significance on the
woman I won't because I don't live in
the United States you come up with all
these different reasons why you can't be
successful instead of focusing on the
things that you have the strengths that
can make you successful and if you look
at every entrepreneur who's achieve
success it was never handed to them they
had to overcome all sorts of crazy
obstacles and adversity to get them
where they are having adversity like
this that's just your ticket in
everybody goes through it we just fight
different demons so for you would
fluency in English for the people who
are up against they have their own fears
as well you just don't see it and the
ones who achieve success are the ones
who stand up to their fears and they
find a way to make it happen let me give
you an example my wife my wife is from
China she's born in China immigrated to
Canada and I said let's make some videos
of you I love how she cooked she makes
some great food and said hey we've got
to take some of these videos some of
these things and you're making turn them
into videos and she was afraid because
english was in her first language and
she has an accent and she makes
grammatical mistakes it's gonna happen
but we did it anyway and you can watch
there's been a couple videos that have
come out there's one where she made
smoothies there's one where she's making
kale chips that are awesome and it's not
just the information that she gets which
is great but it's her cuteness her
passion comes through her wanted people
to be healthy comes through and you
watch it and you learn and you get
absorbed into the video even though
there are a few grammatical mistakes
even though her English isn't perfect
you don't sit there watching it saying
all this person's English is really bad
so I'm not going to watch this video the
key for you to not be nervous and they
be successful is to tap into that
passion just like you did in your email
right you made some mistakes on your
right in your email on this comment but
you still have the courage to send it
out so now you have to get up on stage
and do the same thing you're going to
make mistakes it's not going to be
perfect that's okay you are going to go
up and speak with more passion than
anybody else in that room and that's why
you're going to win last question for
today is from Debbie three laws another
youtube viewer love you guys who wrote
in to say when was the first time your
why of passion Evan and how I'm kind of
distracted person easily interesting a
bunch of subjects studied one subject
but then left it behind and start over
the new one being focused it's hurt I
think does it okay so this is a great
question and one that
a lot of entrepreneurs face how do I
stay focused how do I know this is truly
my path how do I know this is meant for
me or not I'll tell you how I figured it
out okay I I'd sold my business I was
looking for something to do I didn't
know what my next past was and it was
really frustrating it was really sad it
was really depressing because there's
nothing worse than waking up every day
and not knowing what to do and having
that uncertainty that really sucks that
starts to play on your self-confidence
and your sense of worth so I started
trying different things and I got
invited to speak at an event the YMCA
and they said can you come and speak to
our group of young entrepreneurs I said
sure I'd love to give back and try to
help out and they invited me to come and
I prepared for a couple weeks and you
know really wanted to give everything
really want to make it important and
they promoted to their audience and I
told some people about it say hey come
to this free right I'm going to talk
about running a business and I got so
excited member the day of i was nervous
my palms were a little sweaty and I'm
walking into the building to my heart's
beating fast and I get to the elevator
like some deep breaths here we go this
is this is what I was preparing for
really want to help these entrepreneurs
and they plan this huge room and I get
into the room and three people showed up
for this free event three people showed
up and at first I was shocked you know
sad depressed but then thought you know
these people came i gotta and i prepared
i should give them what they came for
and i presented then it and it was
awesome I came out not caring that there
were only three people there those three
people left changed people and I did
that and I felt so grateful and happy
and it was such a high that I felt like
I need to find a way to do this again
and it's it's the why
but not necessarily the how right like
everybody who looked at that would say
that's not a business idea this is this
is never going to work as a business you
can't even get more than three people to
come to a free event how are you going
to turn this into a company Evan come on
I just knew I had to find a way to keep
doing it even if I never got paid to do
it I had to find a way to keep doing it
and eventually I figured it out but it
didn't make any sense logically and I
only came to it by trying stuff so the
only thing worse than you know jumping
from one thing to another to another is
sticking in one thing and hating it
right you're trying one thing you not
having success you're not enjoying it so
you jump that takes courage that takes
guts that's a good thing you don't want
to stick with something maybe because
you're good at it or because the safe
thing to do and then be stuck in this
job or career for 30 years that you hate
and you're living for the weekends and
you're living for the evenings that's
most people that's 90% of America that's
what they get up and do they drive to a
job that they hate so they can come home
I don't want that to be you so if you
don't like something have the courage to
switch is something else until you find
something that you love and you'll find
some things that you try that you hate
instantly and that's okay you know get
rid of them you tried it once you said
you can you can tell people you try to
you can tell yourself you tried it you
know it's not for you fine then you'll
have some things that you try and you
like and you keep doing it maybe become
obsessed with it for a while but then it
fades and so you know you get really
involved in it and then you lose
interest and you move to something else
that's okay too and then you'll hit on
something that you love that you feel
totally fulfilled in that you can't wait
to go and do it again you know I could
talk to entrepreneurs all day long I
could have meetings all day long I could
do videos all day long it it's a it's
been how many years it's been over a
decade and I still love it I still get
energy from it I still get fueled by it
I still love answering questions it's
it's Who I am and I'm so glad that I
discovered it and I may not have
discovered it if if in my despair
in my eggs in my desire to find
something to find purpose and meaning I
jumped into the wrong thing that was
just okay and I stuck with it that was
just okay if I stayed in that role then
I wouldn't be happy and I wouldn't be
doing what I'm doing now so it's okay to
have the courage to switch subjects and
keep searching until you find something
that feels right and like Steve Jobs
said with all matters of the heart
you'll know when you find it so don't
settle thank you guys so much for
watching another edition episode 2 of
the ask Evan show keep believing let me
know what you think leave a comment you
want to see more videos like this
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much for watching I'll see you soon if
you want more believe energy running
through your veins sign up for the
newsletter below it's free you're gonna
love it hi i'm jason j reyez fonseka of
ra's online com and i want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and XD only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period